it's crazy gonna drive the country crazy
we're here in Dearborn Michigan known as
the Arab capital of North America we're
asking folks here what they think about
a trump presidency seems like no matter
what Trump says he just keeps winning
and he sets some pretty alarming things
including about Arabs and Muslims Donald
J Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States I want surveillance of
certain mosques okay if that's okay I
want surveillance
I would Republican now I've become too
McGladrey cousin to be here you know
running amok Rd GLAAD Media Republican
tight
the Donald Trump make you become a
Democrat yes I doubt that he would win I
have hopes and the America and I don't I
don't I don't see that coming
they're gonna be voting for Donald Trump
um probably cuz is pretty an interesting
guy but I think it'll be fun to vote for
a person that's a business guy rather
than a politician what would you do if
he won Iran we gotta take me gonna pray
I don't believe it's gonna be that bad
you know we're all sons are going to be
about it from the country because we
still have well we'll have the
Constitution I don't think I'm working
to change a lot of times why do you
think Donald Trump will be good for
America um he has a lot of new ideas but
it'd be crazy but maybe we need crazy we
need to really vote
he's a president he's a president this
is what the people vote for Kennedy
naamam become a little emerald Iran was
all the trouble
I'm becoming the defense over you didn't
do anything it is our country you belong
here we're gonna we have rights just
like everyone else and hopefully
everything goes the right way